et oui Tom on va d'abord commencer avec
vous Marlène Chapa bonjour avec une
réaction sur l'affaire Bayou est-ce que
Sandrine Rousseau est allé trop loin
dans cette affaire en portant des
accusations sur un plateau de télé sur
une affaire dans les fondements sont
encore assez assez floues assez fragiles
bonjour d'abord ce que je voudrais dire
à cet égard c'est qu'il me semble que le
rôle d'un élu et tout particulier quand
on élu à connaissance de violence
sexistes et sexuelles le rôle d'un élu
CE n'est pas d'enquêter c'est de
signaler il existe et les gens qui
regardent Public Sénat eux ça vient
l'article 40 du code de procédure pénale
qui dit que tout agent public ou
personne en responsabilité lorsqu'elle a
lorsqu'elle est informée de ses faits
doit le signaler pourquoi parce
qu'insiste la permet à la justice de se
saisir d'effet et de dire s'il y a
culpabilité ou innocence et en tout cas
d'instruire les faits qui sont rapportés
ça me semble fondamental alors vous
diriez que finalement le féminisme que
défense en androsso il a certaines
dérives alors que Julien Bayou a
lui-même fait l'objet d'enquête privé de
la part de militante féministe autour de
Sandrine Rousseau j'ai accès à nous
positionne vous moi et nous tous
finalement dans cette situation dans un
rôle extrêmement particulier parce que
je n'ai pas envie de me transformer en
procureur de la République et de devoir
instruire les affaires pour savoir ce
que j'en pense soit il y a des choses
pénalement répréhensibles et donc cette
affaire doit être instruite devant la
justice et donc il faut qu'elle soit en
saisisse soit ce n'est pas le cas et
dans ces cas-là il n'y a pas de raison
que Monsieur Bayou se met en retrait et
je crois que ça nous démontre encore une
fois à quel point les cellules
prétendument contre les violences
sexistes et sexuelles d'Europe Écologie
Les Verts comme celle d'ailleurs de la
France insoumise finalement étouffe la
parole des femmes puisque nous dit que
depuis des mois il y avait des
signalements qui n'ont débouché sur rien
il n'est pas tout de faire des
signalements ou d'entendre cette parole
il faut ensuite savoir que faisons-nous
de cette parole
qui a reconnu avoir giflé sa femme sa
femme qui a porté plainte contre lui en
début de semaine et ce qu'il peut rester
député très bien Roussel appelle à son
départ d'abord dans un premier temps moi
je me suis pas exprimée sur cette
affaire pourquoi parce que j'ai entendu
que l'épouse voulait que s'épouse de
Monsieur cattenans vous voulez qu'on en
parle pas et je sais à titre personnel
En tant que femme à quel point quand on
a envie qu'une affaire soit ne soit pas
médiatisée je pense qu'il faut respecter
là aussi la parole des femmes c'est
pourquoi dans un premier temps je ne me
suis pas exprimée monsieur exprimée
ensuite parce qu'on a entendu pléthore
de cadre important de la France
insoumise relativise minimiser expliquer
qu'une gifle ça n'était pas grave et
j'ai trouvé que c'était un terrible
retour en arrière nous sommes
aujourd'hui à l'anniversaire entre
guillemets des 5 ans du lancement du
mouvement me too on a passé cinq ans et
plus avec le Grenelle des violences
conjugales avec les quatre lois que nous
avons portées pour mieux protéger les
femmes à dire qu'une gifle c'était grave
que frapper une femme c'était
inacceptable on ne peut pas avoir dans
le débat public de retour en arrière sur
ces sujets donc du coup je répète ma
question et ce qu'adrez un cadenas peut
rester député là c'est une question qui
se pose déjà au groupe la France
insoumise et j'observe qu'ils ont un
deux poids de mesure nous nous avons
fait en sorte par exemple quand un
député Benoît Simian était condamné pour
violence conjugale qui soit exclu de
notre mouvement par la commission des
conflits aujourd'hui à notre
porte-parole a annoncé qu'il ne
n'hésitez pas son adhésion puisqu'il
souhaitait réadhérer quelqu'un qui a été
condamné pour des violences conjugales
n'a rien à faire chez Renaissance nous
nous sommes clairs sur ce sujet et
manifestement c'est avec clarté elle
n'existe pas du côté de la France
insoumise puisqu'on parle de quelqu'un
qui a avoué ses félins mais ensuite
c'est à l'huile de le dire moi je vais
pas me joindre au cœur des gens qui
appellent à la démission des autres tous
les quatre matins je pense que c'est une
décision intime personnelle et qui doit
être prise au regard là aussi de la
justice j'ai vu que une enquête était
ouverte et donc il y a une séparation
des pouvoirs ce sera à l'enquête de dire
ce qu'il en est et à lui d'en tirer les
conséquences dans un sens comme dans
l'autre de me rendre je respecte la
présomption d'innocence au regard de la
justice aussi merci beaucoup Marlène
[Musique]